suben los casos y siguen apareciendo
nuevos brotes lo que está obligando a
aumentar las restricciones de movimiento
a acelerar los tests masivos y también a
cerrar algunas ciudades en shanghai fue
detectada el domingo la nueva variante
omicron la más contagiosa y responsable
de las últimas olas en buena parte del
mundo en varios distritos del pulmón
financiero de china se han ordenado
tests masivos con la esperanza de
controlar el brote cuanto antes y evitar
así una segunda cuarentena las
autoridades sanitarias que han advertido
de que los contagios se siguen
produciendo en la comunidad es decir
fuera de los centros de cuarentena de
que el riesgo de que el brote se
extienda por toda la ciudad es muy alto
en una ciudad de jinán una provincia
rural del interior se ha ordenado el
encierro de todos sus vecinos y pekín
anunció la semana pasada que se
convertiría en la primera ciudad de toda
china en exigir el certificado de
vacunación para entrar en algunos de sus
lugares públicos la pandemia también ha
llegado finalmente a macao la capital
del juego mundial y que factura cinco
veces más que las vegas' hasta junio
sólo había contado cientos cuenta casos
pero desde entonces son ya más de 800
así que las autoridades después de
haberlo cerrado casi todo en las últimas
semanas colegios bares restaurantes
cines y gimnasios han tomado finalmente
la decisión más dolorosa han cerrado
también los casinos es un drama porque
supone la paralización económica de
macao porque de ahí sale el 80 por
ciento de sus ingresos